I think the single biggest issue in in
2008 should be where do we want to go as
a country I'm going to be viewed as an
issue per se but in my mind it's the
issue it's the overriding question where
do we want to go as a country do we want
to as a country be willing to say that
we will take a significant part of our
fellow citizens and say you know what
for some of us to do well some of you
cannot are we willing to accept forty
percent of our human capital in
communities of color not to fulfill
their full potential and contribute to a
greater America are we willing to go to
sleep at night saying well I have health
care coverage so I'm not worried about
the 47 million who don't or the millions
more who are underinsured are we
concerned about ensuring that we find
the cures to some of the diseases that
affect our fellow citizens so that my
mother's Alzheimer's or the young man I
met with a spinal cord injury or the
husband with Parkinson's and so many
other diseases are we willing as a
country to say that we accept that that
is a human condition that we cannot
change and are we as a country willing
at the end of the day to say we prefer
to be known by the power of our bombs
than the power of our collective
intellect for good and what that means
in the world
so the big question is what type big
issue is what type of America do we want
to be because if we determine what type
of America we want to be then all the
other things will come and deploy
you